well senator Elizabeth Warren continues
to insist that she is a genuine
american-indian
is in spirit if not genetically and to
support her claim she sets her parents
whom she claims head to a low put doo
doo racist objections to her mother's
part Indian heritage trial Barnes is a
an actual Cherokee genealogist she's
looked into this and she joins us
tonight to tell us what she's found
Twila thanks for coming on thank you so
if you could just settle this for us
since this is something that your expert
in is Elizabeth won a Cherokee Indian no
no she doesn't have she's not enrolled
she has no family on the rolls she has
no indication of Indian ancestry
anywhere in her lineage hmm and yet she
represented herself as one for years and
was promoted on the basis of her claim
that she was an American Indian she also
has this story which she just repeated
the other day about her parents being
subject to the racism of the time
because one of them was part Native
American
what do you know about that is that true
I don't believe it's true they were
married by a prominent minister in a
town just you know maybe 15 miles away
he was prominent enough that he wrote
the the I mean he basically put the that
religion in Oklahoma and helped found a
college there in that religion I don't
think he would have done a wedding for
two kids that ran away and he eloped and
their parents didn't approve also
Elizabeth Warren's father he had at
least one brother and one sister who
also just went and had small weddings
the same way I just think it's the way
their family did things at the time I
don't think it was an elopement yeah
though she's claimed that for years and
held herself up as the victim of
American racism conveniently but nobody
has looked into this really until you
did there's a lot of American Indians in
Oakland
Homa what do they think of these claims
well I can't speak for all of them I
could speak for the ones that I talk to
and you know some just laugh because
it's so ludicrous I mean you know she
has no proof of anything she's a lawyer
and she's supposed to understand you
know you need proof yet she keeps
claiming many are angry because they
feel like she you know she's
appropriating an identity to gain
something from that yeah and she has no
respect for true Native Americans I
think all that's true its identity theft
there's no doubt Twila thank you for
settling that for us I think pretty much
for all time we appreciate it thank you